(audience clapping)
- What's going on everyone?
So thanks for taking 20 minutes out
of a crazy conference schedule
to talk with me about AI initiatives,
and building solid data foundations
on Open Lakehouse Technologies.
So we'll introduce you to Qlik.
If you haven't heard of us.
We'll spend the bulk of the time today
talking about kind of where
the current AI landscape is,
and most specifically
how to build scalable,
but also cost effective data platforms
to drive really any data
initiative that you might have.
But specifically those focused around AI.
Qlik as a company or a
global software company,
offices around the world.
Many of you likely use us
even if you don't know that you use us.
Fundamentally, Qlik
has a product portfolio
that provides customers with
an end-to-end data platform
focused on both data
integration and transformation
as well as data analytics.
So wherever you are in your data journey,
we can likely help get
data into digestible
and consumable formats,
or if your data formats are
in a good state as we speak,
we can help you analyze
and provide analytics
on top of your data.
We are very proud of our AWS partnership.
It's been long lasting
and we hope it will continue
to be into the future.
We've been strategic partners
with AWS for many, many years
and we rely on AWS to power
much of the capabilities
that we're gonna talk through today.
So we're both a partner of AWS,
we're also a consumer of AWS services,
and one of our primary
objectives in partnering with AWS
is to help customers deliver
successful data projects
on AWS as fast as possible, right?
We want to get you from data
to outcome very quickly,
very easily, and really
enable all of your data
professionals to be successful,
driving data projects on AWS.
So AI's happened, right?
I don't think I'm out of
bounds by saying that,
if you look at the maturity curve,
we're kind of inside of it, right?
Most organizations are
starting, continuing,
starting to deliver AI projects
within their organization.
So it's really up to us
as data professionals
and as data teams to figure out
how we're gonna build
strong data platforms
and strong data foundations,
to deliver successful AI initiatives.
And many organizations are
starting to make progress, right?
I think it's good to see that
almost 70% of organizations
have started to build a
formalized AI strategy, right?
Pretty rare these days to
approach an organization
and they have no strategy
or no developed plans
for accommodating AI.
What has become really challenging though,
and one of the factors
that I think is starting to hold it back,
is that ROI can be really hard to predict
and quantify on AI projects.
And many organizations are
struggling to kind of dip
their toe all the way into the water,
'cause they're not sure
whether they're gonna get
the perceived benefit
out of those projects.
So that has started to
slow down the rollout
across the industry, though
you're seeing lots of successful
AI initiatives, a lot of
them around kind of chatbot
type engagements, code
reading and development.
And we're starting to
see more AI initiatives
fall into the analytics
perspective and realm.
If you talk to organizations
about what's holding them back,
though, we talked about
kind of the difficulty
in predicting ROI,
but a lot of the barriers
are around that data foundation, right?
You can't really do
anything with your data
if you can't trust your data, right?
So how do you build that
strong data foundation,
and that strong data platform,
that you can then deliver
successful AI projects on top of?
And that is something
that we're talking to
a lot of customers about,
and they're telling us
that it's holding them back
on achieving a lot of their vision
around some of these projects
that they want to implement.
So how do we start to
make progress, right?
How can we start to build
on these data foundations
and these data platforms to deliver
on our successful projects?
We at Qlik believe that it all starts
with an open data architecture.
And we'll talk about what that means,
and how we can deliver on
that through the remainder
of today's presentation.
So what does an architecture look like
in terms of these open foundations?
So if you look across
the left of the screen,
that's your data.
Those are your data sources, right?
This is where the data's gonna come from
that you want to build
your projects on top of.
And we believe in open architecture
should support as many
sources as you might have,
from the simple maybe API endpoints,
or SAS type applications,
to the more complicated maybe
database transactional systems
that you may want to bring
into your data architectures,
the Oracles of the world,
SQL servers of the world,
PostgreSQL, all the way down
to the much more complicated
streaming realtime data sources, right?
Those sources that deliver
semi-structured data,
those sources that
deliver data in real time,
those sources who schema
evolves over time.
All of these sources need to be brought in
to a particular data architecture.
Now that then data architecture
then needs to provide
capabilities to help you
move and transform that data
into that, that is of high quality.
So a data platform that is open,
needs to handle the data movement
and that also needs to be
able to analyze and act
on that data in the most
efficient way possible.
And we believe that an
open data lake architecture
is the best place to store
and manage your data,
so that it is available to
as many different consumers
as might want to consume it.
These could be AI agents,
these could be traditional
data consumers like analytical
and query engines, right?
So this is what a proposed
architecture looks like,
and we think that iceberg
formatted lakehouse
is the best approach
for storing your data.
And there's two primary reasons for that.
If you talk to customers
about why they're considering
adopting iceberg or Lakehouse
solutions in general,
most of those conversations
drive towards one,
or two particular drivers.
The first is cost, right?
When building out these architectures
that have to accommodate any
data source that we might have,
from the small scale to the large scale,
from the batch oriented to the real time,
cost is going to be a factor
in bringing that data in.
And Lakehouse technology,
specifically those based on Iceberg,
have proven to deliver the
most flexible data storage
at the lowest possible cost.
The second value proposition
is interoperability.
We are trying to help organizations shift
from what I would call platform
oriented architectures,
where all data sits
inside of the platform,
consuming that data, to
a more open architecture,
where the data can sit inside
of an open architecture
and then as many platforms as you want,
can connect you and consume that data.
And Iceberg serves as a very
powerful framework for that,
as proven by what you
see over on the right,
right across the industry
most vendors, AWS of course,
leading the charge, have chosen Iceberg
as a Lakehouse format that they're putting
a lot of eggs into that basket.
AWS has services like S3 tables,
a variety of glue services,
SageMaker, EMR, Glue, Athena,
all of them very well support
Iceberg within the AWS ecosystem.
And across the industry, whether
data warehouse providers,
other hyper scalers, variety
of consumption engines,
they all have chosen Iceberg as a format
and a technology that
they will support, right?
So this interoperability
across the data ecosystem
is a huge value add of
any Lakehouse technology,
specifically those based on Iceberg.
And Qlik, of course is
now in that world, right?
We released earlier this
year the Qlik Open Lakehouse,
that has introduced a
managed Iceberg offering
within the Qlik product portfolio,
that we can help customers
ingest data into,
transform data within,
and then present out to
their consumption engines.
If I layer this on top of
the architecture diagram
that you saw earlier, you can
see the Qlik Open Lakehouse,
powered by Apache
Iceberg that runs on AWS,
provides three primary capabilities.
So first you'll see high
throughput ingestion,
that's ingestion directly
into Iceberg tables,
from all of the various
sources that I mentioned,
from the simple API type endpoints,
to the more complicated
database and CDC type endpoints,
all the way through,
we're happy to announce at this show,
new support for streaming data ingestions,
from streaming providers
like Amazon Kinesis,
various versions of Kafka,
even Micro-Batch ingestions
for many files that might
exist on object stores.
All of that data can be very simply
and cost-effectively
ingested into Iceberg tables.
Now, beyond that Iceberg ingestion though,
any customer who's tried
to use Iceberg at scale,
will know that Iceberg,
if it's not optimized,
will not deliver on its core value,
especially real-time ingestion.
Iceberg tables need to be optimized.
You have to compact files for
efficient file level access.
You have to expire snapshots,
so your metadata files
remain reasonably sized.
You have to delete orphan files,
so that you're not
consuming terabytes on disc
to process a hundred gigabyte data set.
And the click adaptive optimizer will do
all of that for you.
As you ingest data into
Iceberg, our optimizer kicks in,
and we continuously optimize
Iceberg for low cost,
and great performance.
And then finally we have
warehouse mirroring.
And this is an important component
of the interoperability
function that I mentioned.
It's not good enough to
store your data in Iceberg,
and just query it from a single engine.
Iceberg tables need to be
consumable by as many possible
consumption engines as
possible in order to deliver
on that open perspective.
So what we offer is we
ingest data into Iceberg,
we optimize Iceberg,
and then we can present that data
to a variety of consumption engines
from your data warehouses,
to your query engines,
so that they can reach into
the Qlik Open Lakehouse,
and run optimized queries
against Iceberg tables.
And all of this runs on AWS.
As an example of the cost efficiency
that we're helping customers achieve,
we actually ran a benchmark,
we just published this
benchmark a few weeks ago.
We took the exact same data,
it was a real time streaming
ingestion into Iceberg,
relatively, I'll call it
moderate volume, right?
So not low scale, not high scale,
kind of right in the middle.
Probably a volume similar
to what many of you
are working with today.
We ingested that data in real time.
This is a real time use case into a
Qlik Open Lakehouse Iceberg table.
And then conversely, we
ingested the same data
directly into a data warehouse.
To just showcase the cost
efficiency that you can see
with Open Lakehouse
ingestion into Iceberg.
The conclusion of the benchmark
was that we were able to
deliver data freshness
at a magnitude of five x faster, right?
So data latency you can
see in the Open Lakehouse
was in the one to three minute range,
and the data warehouse was in
the five to 15 minute range.
So again, five x faster data,
and we could do that at a lower
cost in the 75 to 90% range.
We actually ran the test on a
few different warehouse sizes
from the very small to
the slightly larger.
And we were able to showcase
not only fresher data
into Iceberg, but at a much lower cost.
And then again, you get to take advantage
of the interoperability
of those Iceberg tables,
that are now consumable across
the widest range of query engines.
So if you look online,
we published this
benchmark a few weeks ago.
There's a lot of detail
information on how you can
replicate it yourself, but again,
delivering on that cost
efficiency at scale objective,
of getting data into Iceberg
in an efficient manner.
So again, Open Lakehouse
benefits, very fresh,
high speed realtime data
ingestion into Iceberg,
at a very low cost.
And with the adaptive
optimizer layered on top,
so that you get great
query performance out
of your Iceberg tables,
again, while benefiting
from the cost savings that we see,
by ingesting data into an Open Lakehouse.
So that's what I wanted
to talk about in slides.
I did prepare a quick demo if
you wanna see how this works,
but I will say if you wanna
see an even better demo
than the one I'm gonna show
you, come to the click booth.
It is literally as far
that way as you can walk
in the expo hall.
So if you go way that way, you
can listen for the cowbells
or see people huffing
and puffing on bikes,
then you'll know you're
in the right space.
What this demo is, this
is a real streaming data,
IoT style use case where you
can generate your own data.
So you get on the bikes, you
pedal as fast as you want,
during your ride, you're gonna generate
about 300 to 500 meter readings
that we're pulling off of the bike,
realtime sensor data that we
then load into Amazon Kinesis,
a realtime streaming platform.
We ingest that data into
Iceberg tables in real time.
We optimize those tables
so that we get great query performance,
and then we're providing
analytics capabilities
on top of the data that you've generated
while riding the bike.
So it's both kind of
a fun user experience,
but also a real world example
of real time streaming data
ingestion into Iceberg.
And if you wanna see how this works,
I'm going to keep my fingers crossed
that I can switch to a demo. Perfect.
Now those of you know, the
wifi in here is not great.
So I am gonna take
advantage of a recording.
I normally don't do this.
I like to do demos live,
but so that I'm not
suffering from wifi issues.
I'm just gonna run the recording,
and I'll kind of talk you
through what we're seeing here.
So this is our click town cloud platform,
specifically our Open Lakehouse solution.
And we're gonna build a
streaming ingestion project.
We'll give our product a name,
and we're gonna define the Iceberg details
of how we want to ingest this data.
So the catalog, we're gonna use AWS glue,
the storage engine, AWS S3,
and then a compute cluster
that runs in AWS to process
that data into Iceberg and
optimize that data continuously
as it's being ingested.
We step through a data onboarding wizard.
This is where we select our
Amazon Kinesis connection.
This is where those real time events
are gonna get loaded to.
And we have two Kinesis
streams in this account.
This is like an e-commerce type data set.
And we're gonna pull those
two different Kinesis streams
into Open Lakehouse.
Our data's in JSON format.
We do support a variety of formats.
So any type of data, whether
it's highly structured,
or less structured, we can pull in
and ingest as a part of this process.
And we have options to
determine how far back
do we wanna read, how do we
want to handle nested data?
If you're using like JSON,
and if you've got structs,
or arrays, we can either keep
it nested or flatten it out,
we can append or merge.
And then we can also define
the partitioning of the table
that we're ingesting into.
So we build out the project,
here's a picture of an
end-to-end pipeline from Kinesis
into landing for raw data and
then processed into Iceberg.
And from here now we've
got a running pipeline
that in real time is taking
data from source event
in Kinesis into a queryable Iceberg table
at very low latency, right?
Over the course of the event,
we've done almost 2 million
bike sensor readings,
and growing, so we'll probably
be much higher than that
after the event finishes.
But this is just an example
of a running pipeline
processing data into Iceberg.
And here's an example of
AWS Athena then querying
that Iceberg table with near
realtime freshness, right?
So whether you're using Athena
or any other query engine
that you might have access to,
you can run those queries
against the Iceberg tables.
Lastly, how do you trust that data?
The click town cloud platform
has this concept of data quality.
Every data set that we
ingest data into is assigned
a trust score that's based on accuracy,
validity, semantic quality
of that data, completeness,
so that you can also know
not only are we ingesting
this data Into Iceberg,
but we're delivering data
that you can trust.
It's of the highest quality.
And you can measure that
and monitor that over time.
So that's the click town cloud platform.
And that's the example of a
real-time streaming ingestion
into Iceberg.
But very simple. You set it up once.
You set it in, forget it,
everything runs continuously.
Everything is optimized for you.
Cost is managed and kept low,
but that data is accessible
to the widest possible
variety of query engines.
So again, if you'd like
to try out this use case
for yourself, definitely
come by the booth.
You can either just ride
the bikes and work up
a little sweat or it's only
about a 30 second ride,
you probably won't work
up too much of a sweat,
but you can kind of try
out the bikes for yourself,
generate some data, and
then we can walk you through
the end-to-end data
pipeline that you yourself
have participated in and kind of see
how that data's ingested, processed,
and then finally stored an Iceberg
and served up to a variety
of analytics use cases.
So I do wanna thank everyone
for your time today.
I'll peel off over there
if anyone has any questions
that you want to ask before
the next session starts.
Again, if you wanna learn more about Qlik,
please come find us in the booth.
Walk that way as far as you can.
Listen for the cowboys, cowboys, cowbells.
Listen or watch for the
spinning click logo, come over,
ride the bike, see a demo.
We'd love to talk further.
Thank you all for your time today.
I know it's a jam packed agenda,
and I'm very thankful that
you were able to spend
20 minutes with me here today.
You can come find me right over there,
or in the click booth over
the rest of the conference.
So thanks everyone.